they're rough they're tough there are
lethal weapons in the war against
boredom those two undercover cops Mel
Gibson and Danny Glover
do something all these people watching
all over the wall
with all these big stars in this show
making all those wonderful speeches but
what can we say that so that 1 billion
people won't forget us keep it you're
showing yeah yeah ah we got it okay the
nominees of achievement in
cinematography are Michael Baumann
broadcast news it Torrio's tomorrow for
the last emperor belief russello open
has the Wechsler to make
Allen Debbie oh for Empire of the Sun
and the winner is the winner is Vittorio
Storaro of Alaska
oh my god I really would like to thanks
all the Academy members for this
wonderful recognition because for me
this is not only a recognition for one
single achievement in cinematography for
one movie this is really recognition for
a life experience because last temper
really represents for me the result or
20 years of collaboration with Bernardo
Bertolucci a long difficult hard journey
they were so made beautiful by a
traveling guide by a friend like
Bernardo I really do think they into
last emperor that is not only one movie
but there is all our self thank you very
much